as copic 19 cases rise so do concerns
for new parents
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to a chief nursing officer at
centennial hills hospital
who tells us what they're doing to keep
every mother and newborn
safe my due date was supposed to be
november 22nd
fabiana pereira went into labor sunday
right before that that weekend on friday
my um
husband found out that he was
around someone who tested positive for
cobin her husband
also tested positive he could not be
with her
for the delivery i was devastated the
next choice
her mom but she and her mom also had to
get tested
my mom's was negative and then mine came
back
positive but after having the baby i
was not expecting it because i don't
have any symptoms
i feel completely fine janet wright is
the chief
operating nurse at centennial hills
hospital she says more expectant moms
are testing positive if the moms do come
in and we learn that they're positive
we do have our protocols that we put
into place
so they do go into isolation as for
pereira the hospital has a plan
for her and her baby when they go home
the baby needs to stay
quarantined or in isolation for the same
amount of time as the mother
but then once the mother has been
cleared the baby should still stay
quarantined for 14 more days expert
advice for new moms in such scary times
and also some advice from a new mom it
is serious
clearly it's affecting families
people with little kids and
i feel like if we all just like think
about each other
then we can just hurry up and get this
over with sally jaramillo 8 news now
and just this month centennial hills
hospital expanded its maternity
department
the birthplace as it's called added a
couple of labor and delivery suites
along with 36
mother baby sweets